In the last two weeks, my CA-153 tumor marker has decreased by 47 points, that's great news.
But by alkaline phosphatase, many times that's breathing ALK on your comprehensive metabolic profile,
alkaline phosphatase went from 82 to 111.
High starts at 104, so remember the lab values for high are going to be different depending on the lab.
Many of the access lab and lab core I think it's over 120 is considered high.
Optimal range really anything over 100 is considered high.
So yes, 111 is high.
I calcium went from 10.9 to 11.1.
Okay, so there's a margin of error there, so pretty much you could say that stayed the same.
My question is what is considered high alkaline phosphatase and how long could it stay there?
Well, I understand you have lab ranges and optimal ranges.
So the lab ranges can vary typically high level or optimal range or functional range is 100.
Some people would even say a little bit less than that.
So 111 is certainly high, but also you have to take a consideration of what can be normal for a person.
Now you've had multiple labs passed in your alkaline phosphatase in the past has always ranged on the low end of normal.
So then you know any elevation, even though it might still be lower than 100, let's say it was 98, but you always ranged at the low end of normal.
You'd have to consider that that's high.
So you're looking at when you're looking at lab values, you're looking at previous labs done, which way is the lab trending and how is it correlated to other different values in the test.
What alkaline phosphatase elevates along with calcium, the first thing you think of at least it would give you a clue that the elevation is due to bully destruction.
Because elevated alkaline phosphatase can be from multiple different reasons.
If you have irritation to the liver from taking a medication, let's say if I'm in this all or I'm impacted, that can elevate alkaline phosphatase, but typically would spare calcium.
If alkaline phosphatase and calcium go up together, you'd think it would be coming from bone.
Remember, alkaline phosphatase can become from tissue destruction, especially in bone, and especially if we know that there's mates to bone.
So what is high? We're going to say there's been people with alkaline phosphatase in the 300, 600, go to say it's with acute liver distress.
But the point is is that you want to be looking at the trend.
If a person is thinking that let's say they're on fentanyzol and or Ivermectin, and it is working to decrease the cancer.
Let's say in this case, two markers are going down, alkaline phosphatase is going up. Could it be because of the continuous of the fentanyzol?
It could be, is that at 111 at a danger mark where we have to cut the fentanyzol and Ivermectin? I would say no.
Unless the person's normal alkaline phosphatase prior to getting cancer was like 28 or so low number, that would be lab low.
But no, I would say you're safe still. Got at a danger for liver shutdown at 111.
Continuation of that question, it seems like the Ivermectin at the fentanyzol are working more so than Ivermectin since I was taking the fentanyzol a month.
Oh, before, alone in my CA, 15, 3, and CA 27, 29, two markers went from 100 to 200 during that month.
I don't want liver damage. I don't want to disrupt my progress either.
Could the higher alkaline phosphatase be for the bodesmets? And also a lagging indicator.
Yes, both those, like I said, both those could be true. Have labs scheduled for another two weeks or no.
And that's really the key. I know a lot of people don't like to go and get labs.
There's a cost to getting labs if you can't get your insurance to pay for them.
But seeing them more frequently would be more beneficial.